But it was when I picked up the course
in miracles,
which doesn't claim to be for everybody.
But if the two of you,
you know it,
what I got from the course in miracles
and I was in my mid twenties at the
time.
I'm not saying that this had not been
another things that I read,
but for whatever reason I didn't get it
from other things I had read.
And that's that there is no coming to
God except to the person in front of you
that that is,
you know,
the course of miracles says belief in
God is doesn't mean anything.
It's the experience of God and the
experience of God is our love for each
other.
I love how in the course it says,
some people conspire with God who do not
yet believe in him.
It's like you and I were talking before
about atheism and so forth.
So,
yeah,
I learned that the loving other people,
everything is secondary.
And my capacity to reach across the wall
that separates me from others through my
own judgment,
to my own attack thoughts,
uh,
to my own failure to take
responsibility,
self righteousness or whatever that work
on myself is the spiritual work.
Ah,
pay yourself so that you are able to
feel God or love or whatever where it's
convenient in your relationships with
other people.
This is,
that'd is the experience at the cod.
Oh,
tell us more.
While the course in miracles says there
is no getting to heaven,
um,
this says heaven is entered two by two.
You cannot get there unless you take
someone with you.
And Heaven is not a condition or a
place,
but an awareness of our oneness.
So the course is not trying to get us to
believe in God.
It's trying to get us to believe in each
other.
If you're in front of me,
you're my spiritual lesson and you're my
path to God.
The courses everyone you meet will
either be your crucified or your savior
depending on what you choose to be to
them.
Uh,
on my own,
like just literally on my mom to moment
feel like a lot of my life was somehow
this ossification of loneliness,
of dreadful solitude,
pain of loneliness.
I revisit it somehow often when alone,
even briefly,
intermittently like,
uh,
you know,
I arrive here,
it's late,
I go to the room and I feel sort of
headachy and post flighty and alone.
And I have to remember that when I
talked to other people,
if I prepare myself in the manner in
which you have described,
I will feel God and loving other people
even in just incidental communication.
Like when I talked to her personal,
excuse me,
do you know if there's any yoga here and
the person really takes,
oh yeah.
Let me try and find it.
I think,
oh yeah.
People are beautiful sometimes on my own
I get pretty scared.
Like,
you know,
like,
oh,
I'm going to be attacked or people won't
be beautiful or the world won't take
care of me.
Have you over time,
been able to come cultivate a sense of
this,
a faith in God through relationships
that will be sustainable even in periods
of solitude,
suffering,
pain,
an insurance.
Yes.
How did that happen?
And when I have been these times of
pain,
I wonder when was the time of wilderness
for you or the garden?
I wrote a book called tears to triumph,
which is exactly about that,
about the application of spiritual
principles to human despair.
One of the issues that has been very,
um,
that I've been very passionate about is
talking about they sociopathic economics
and how,
um,
even human pain will be turned into a
profit center if there's money to be
made for some corporation.
Um,
I'm very concerned about what I think of
as the psychotherapeutic
psychopharmacological industrial
complex,
which has chosen,
uh,
for the sake of $1 billion industry to
medicalize human despair.
And the truth of the matter is,
um,
depression.
And I'm not talking about bipolar or,
or schizophrenia that's outside my lane
outside of my purview.
But the normal spectrum of human despair
is my lane.
Because the real spiritual path does not
just take a yellow smiley face like this
and put it over everything.
I'll be happy,
be happy.
Buddha would not have begun his path of
enlightenment.
And until he crossed his father's walls
and saw suffering for the first time,
Moses was sent by God to the Israelites
because they were suffering in,
in Egypt as slaves and Jesus suffered on
the cross.
So the real spiritual outlook recognizes
the suffering of the human condition
when we are living outside the context
of our love for each other.
So that,
you know,
if you,
if you had a heartbreak,
uh,
divorce,
financial failure,
bankruptcy,
lost someone you love,
these things are painful,
but they're not mental illnesses and
what us,
and that's why in that book I write,
this is what Buddhism says.
This is what the Old Testament says is
what the New Testament says.
Aa or anything else you,
you,
that's why you keep coming back.
Because it's a rough day to day.
It's recognize it's a rough day to day.
It's recognized.
It's a rough day to day.
And if you're left on your own,
God knows what your mind might lead you
to do.
So when you know principals,
whatever your path is,
um,
and you practice them.
So you asked about myself.
Um,
okay.
Marianne.
Um,
and I've,
I've lived two periods of time that by
any,
by any means today would be called
clinical depression.
But even that's such a scam.
All that means that somebody in a clinic
set it.
There is no blood test,
right?
But if you've been there,
you,
you know it.
Okay?
Marianne,
you number one,
you don't even think this is going to be
done quickly.
So none of this like just,
you know,
today people say,
well,
your mother died a month ago.
Aren't you over it yet?
No.
Okay.
It's gonna take time.
Number two,
who are the safe people who can
accompany you on this?
Who are the people who will bear witness
to your agony during this time?
What are the things that you're gonna
need to support you?
Make sure you have a lot of a bubble
bath.
Uh,
make sure that you stay with your
meditation even though you don't want to
stay with your prayer work.
Uh,
make sure you show up for other people.
You will be,
you will have a tendency to isolate
during this period of time.
You must not do that.
You must get up and work.
Your subconscious will put aside your
despair while you're showing up for
other people.
And then when you come back from that,
you'll go back to crying again.
There was an art to navigating despair.
There is an art to navigating depression
and the spiritual spiritual principles
lead us there.
There are seasons of life.
I quote in that book from Roca where he
says,
let me not squander the hour of my pain.